[Music]
mary is in kalamazoo michigan hi mary
welcome to the ramsay show
hi hi dave
oh my gosh what a privilege it is to
speak with you you too um
oh thank you
um
so i have something kind of laying heavy
on my heart and i was hoping to seek
your advice
um
so i'm 31 years old my husband is
a couple years older than me and my
daughter is sick
i have a very close relationship with my
parents and they're in their 70s
they recently informed me that
my daughter and i
will be receiving
a little over a million dollars
in inheritance when they pass away
which is is wonderful that's very
generous
what i'm having a hard time with is
i'm adopted they're not my biological
parents
and they also informed me that my
brother
who is my father's biological son will
not even be receiving half of that
and
he and i don't have a good relationship
anyways i mean it's civil we're not
close by any means we're he's 20 years
older than i am
um why the discrepancy and
i i think it's because they don't have a
very close relationship with him
he's from my father's first marriage
um
and they didn't raise them together
okay
so how can we help
so
my question is how can i get over this
build and
if and when they pass um
how do i maintain a good relationship
with my brother when that happened
it sounds like you don't have a great
relationship right now with your brother
it's civil we enjoy seeing each other
but we we just have
such a huge age gap
and just completely different lives that
we don't really communicate with each
other that much yeah
okay i think you need to free yourself
of this because it's not a decision you
made
so there's nothing to feel guilty about
there's relational equity that you have
with the family and that turns into
financial equity with the inheritance
the um
guilt would be if you did something you
didn't do anything
so and i think it's probably named wrong
uh instead let's name it something else
because i get that you have angst about
it i i get that you feel kind of like uh
why you know this is gonna not gonna go
well and i'm gonna get blamed you know
that's kind of how it feels right
so i don't i don't know what we call
that but guilt would be if you did
something wrong you didn't do anything
so this is not on you
um you know unless you manipulated your
parents into a bigger inheritance but
that's not what you said so i'm going
with you i'm going with your story
so uh first let's just say out loud your
parents are cowards
to dump this on you
they should call they should call him up
and tell him what he's getting and what
you're getting they did that with you
they they have informed him
that you're getting a million and he's
getting a half
he's getting about three hundred
thousand okay have they told him what
you're getting
i
believe so they thought that they would
all right so i had to ask them to that's
good that's what they should do i'll
retract my statement that they're not
cowards then if they did that because
they're dumping the problem of the
relational angst on you upon their death
if they don't handle it while they're
alive and so we tell people read the
will while you're alive and tell
everybody what they're getting and if
somebody's going to be pissed let's go
ahead and deal with it while i'm alive
and so if they've done that then i guess
brothers already got it figured out that
you didn't do anything
he already knows
okay
i would verify that they did that
with her with them i mean you told him
how much i'm getting and how much he's
getting if not you should mom and dad
because it's not fair to leave me
looking like the bad dog
the bad person at the end of this story
because i didn't do anything here
right okay and if they do that then
maybe brother just looks at it and goes
okay
i don't really talk to him that much
anyway and she hangs out over there all
the time i get it
like i have a relative who will leave
100
of their money
to
one child and will leave the other child
nothing who they have no relationship
with
and that's completely understandable i
have a relative that's doing that right
now
and i agree with it by the way
and that's okay but but you shouldn't
you shouldn't you know you're not
entitled to money just because of your
dna you're entitled to the money if
somebody wants to leave it to you it's
their money they get to do with what
they want and so he has no real gripe
to start with and so he's three hundred
thousand ahead of what he should be
probably but um the thing is not letting
his resentment and anger towards her be
a reflection of her character right this
is has nothing to do with it you didn't
write this narrative
you just are in the story you didn't
write the story and so um i get that it
feels icky and i don't i really don't
disagree with you about that the only
way to remove that is shine when when
stuff is
awkward or weird the best way to clean
it up is shine light on it
call it out and all the roaches run to
the corner as soon as you turn on the
lights and so if you'll go ahead and
just call it out if they've already
called it out then he has the
opportunity to interact with them and if
he wants to be mad at you i guess he can
be he may call you and say i'm pissed at
you i don't know but at least he can get
all that out of the way now before the
money actually transfers
and um
and even then you just go
i didn't do it you know yeah you have a
conversation with them go hey i know
this is weird i had nothing to do with
this i still want to have this
relationship with you i love you yeah
you know and you move on from there and
if he can't handle that that's on him
that relationship can't move on exactly
this is not she's just a good person and
with a big heart and she feels that
sweet well you feel it it is an
awkwardness crud
thing but the way to get rid of the
awkward is for mom and dad to tell him
the same thing they told her and the why
behind it
if the why is if they can do it without
being nasty
you know
and just go
this is just our decision and
you know you don't even have to you
don't have to hurt his feelings too
you know just tell him what he's getting
is what she's getting and leave it at
that i
yeah
but this is why you do a will and this
is why you read the will out loud before
you die to all parties concerned so that
everyone knows what's going on and you
can go ahead and get all that weirdness
out of the way
and that's a good
that's a good question and it's good you
have a good heart for worrying about it
but
i think it's on him and on them it's not
on you she's got to release it